[Music]
uh editor i'm recording this because uh
you're gonna cause people to panic
uh bob save file is still there so the
world we have is still okay
i'm just starting over no need to panic
we picked up where we were
i was just the idiot when did i open
that door
so you're not the same character even
though you're yeah apparently not that's
weird
uh well new computer i don't know why
that would do that
why didn't it sync up any saves or
anything but at least the world is here
so
no no no no you guys know no everyone
thinks i'm an idiot no you guys don't
understand
the continue button was grayed out
oh you know maybe i'm dumb maybe that's
it maybe i'm just an idiot
if you just press the continue button
you would have been right back here with
us
why wouldn't you press continue oh no
i forgot that there's people gotta watch
out for that dude
i saw one of those six leg things oh
wow oh god i went to throw my spear at a
rabbit that was
two feet in front of me and i managed to
overthrow the entire island we live on
and it landed in the river were you
bragging or complaining i shoveled one
driveway in the middle of the night and
all of a sudden my muscles are so
big that i can't even just throw a stick
one foot i had to throw it 500 feet
my muscles are so big
oh that's a loud cry hey did you know
there's things out in the forest here
i'm back baby did you
miss me wha bam yeah
you're right hey how's it going hey
what's up how's it going in the base
here
good good good
wait mark mark you at the base yeah
what's up all right catch
what what yeah
yeah does that make it in no it did not
matter
that little tank the sound of a spear
landing on the ground near us
i threw it from about six miles away i
didn't know you could throw a spear how
do you make a spear again
upgrade spear i don't have bones uh
you guys got any spare bones i can we
have a bone box don't we
do we have a bone box yeah we totally do
have a bone box where's the bone box
oh my god we have a bone box is there
three in here exactly three thank you
exactly how many there was thank you my
dudes
thank you goodly how do we make an
upgraded spear oh the bones i see what
you're doing
sorry did i take the bones that you
needed
i lost my chainsaw my sacks god damn it
i lost a lot of stuff but i'll make it
back it's okay
i have rabbit fur boots in my inventory
that i can either
equip nor unequip you got a bird next to
you
oh how do you throw hold left yeah there
you go gotcha
gotcha then like aim so aim out and then
just like
launch the [ __ ] thing look how far
you throw that [ __ ] oh this bird's gonna
get
god damn it you bird [ __ ] we should go
to a cave
right where are them i could pull up a
map
i know where one is across the water
that has a chainsaw in it
or the climbing gear was that the
climbing gear or the chainsaw we got
both oh mark you're gonna have to get
the climbing gear probably though oh
my god you're right oh god damn it i
just lost
i lost my spear oh i threw it over here
oh my god where's my spirit
my spirit um hmm what what
all right mark my beard's gone i threw
it literally trying to get a bird it
went over the hill and then
what yeah right man it's just gone
we'll make another one not special
well you know where there's so many
people harvest some bones from ah
you're right yeah okay okay i think we
gotta go get the climbing gear
for me or i can go get it myself i won't
burden you you guys
are probably with you it's okay you guys
can come with if you want
i like i i i well no that's what i'm
saying is like
you're gonna totally die if we don't
come help you well uh you have no chance
in the world without us i mean maybe but
i didn't want to risk you guys lives it
was more of like a sweet
either but you know whenever you don't
hit continue it's kind of you put us in
a weird position yeah
mark are you at the cave yet i'm gonna
go am i allowed to go
am i allowed to go yeah well i'm waiting
man i'm just chopping logs over here
okay i'm going i was
you know just some emotional things i
had to deal with i got no
food and no plans mark knows
how to live i do i've done it before
and i'll do it again okay hey did we
pick up this picture beforehand
oh it's a treasure map
that sounds useful yeah probably
remember a treasure map
i don't know man look i don't know i'm
going in the cave it's very dark i
should have made a torch or something
torch torch i don't see torch here i'm
pretty sure upgraded stick is torch i'm
like ninety percent sure okay okay okay
okay let me light it
was it just like a rag and a stick yeah
yeah yeah yeah that just
okay yeah it's just torch okay cool you
know for a torch it really doesn't do
that much light oh
didn't we to figure out that if you just
hit l you'll just get your lighter out
yeah which is kind of adequate yeah yeah
that was terrible it didn't even it
didn't work right on my screen
yeah yeah yeah there's very likely no
monsters anymore here i bet
i would bet it's not like they respawn
or breed or i don't know what they do to
make more
but clone yeah it's not like they clone
coming down the rope bro all right bro
that sounds good bro god the
the menacing chainsaw really gets me
every time
that's my bad that's why that i'm trying
i'm trying to remember all my keybinds
i got the chainsaw ooh now you can do
menacing chainsaws yeah i love menacing
i'm not seeing many uh anything so i
think actually it might actually be
empty actually hey i see
a guy in the middle of the water mark
you just oh
he's moving i don't believe you higher
shoulders
hey the the but the hole has already
been blown so we're good
on me hut on me ah man that's
unfortunate
wait wait a minute mark where are you at
i'm hearing shuffling noises
i heard you dude i heard you're
shuffling to help you it's fine is there
any shuffling down there
yeah no you're aware of maybe
here's a bunch of bones and whatnot i
see hey it's another treasure map
oh nice i think i actually know where
that isn't that isn't this the one the
plateau above our
above our base oh wait is this a little
secret thing yeah
free gun ammo did you guys get the gun
ammo gun ammo no
there's a there's gun ammo for me right
there's one of the skulls here that's
correct
damn okay i'm here in
that's water rushing right okay yeah
that's not peep that's not
many feet here we are dragging through
water right people rushing yes
is it people rushing ah good great
down i go good pick up the chainsaw
manual
and then the climbing gear all right
we're good great
well that was easy we just uh get out of
here right we just get out of here
all right see you boys we both okay
i'll see you boys see you boys
all right later boys later boys
i have one inch visible this is awful
i don't know what's wrong with your
settings but the lighter is not that bad
good oh nice leap dude thank you i just
don't
trust the water some candy bars on the
ground there
nothing better than cave candy bars see
you later boys
wait boys i can't daddy can't see boys
later boys hearts
good this is the heart is there anything
else here i fix and change the color
gradient
come over here why let's wait to ambush
wade
okay
in the corner i'll never see it
oh you casually rev your chin
please don't aim it at me and click
that's bad it's bad
i need to put it in my bag for quick
access anyway
all right my lads i'm climbing out oh
hey bob i [ __ ] got here despite not
being able to see a damn thing hello
wait
i have the exact same light technology
that you have yeah
yeah you're game pro it's black
i went through you wade you need to do a
deep cleaning of your colon
tight tight it's so tight it's the
tightest actually
um can one of you pull up the map of the
caves
there's a guy running over there i don't
really want to be looking at maps
you see them oh there's a whole bunch
wait where are they going mark there
a herd of them is traveling let me put
away my noisy chainsaw
this is just literally a picture of some
trees no oh you gotta go online to look
up a map of caves sorry there is a map
in the game that we can get that will
help build us actually a map but it's in
one of the caves
oh no the herd is returning mark why
they're they're
they're coming back from whence they
came well let's go away from once they
came
i just remembered i lost my spear but
that's okay i'll forgive myself
it was a good spear that you had i can't
believe i got two throws with that thing
and i got no kills and i'm so sad
but yeah it was pretty bad yeah it was
pretty bad
but you win some you lose some and i
lost
oh what the heck i can't i'm
i'm going to bed oh we we can't no it's
a timed out
unfortunately looks like we're going to
stay up tonight
have a little party like mead is back
off the menu boys
all right boys i'm gonna put a leg on
the barbecue try to get some goddamn
bones out of here oh wait i can sleep
now mark
okay what what i able to sleep
well i can't sleep i can't sleep i can't
sleep what
you can't sleep up i can't sleep i can't
sleep oh no there's an option to eat
that leg
i don't think that'd be what would
happen if i eat that leg bad
i'm gonna eat that leg all right
all right so let's see where where are
we well i feel
fine honestly it was pretty good guys
you should eat the meat
it's got a safe map up goodness figure
out where exactly we are
pretty tasty not gonna know where we are
guys not gonna lie
what was that sound i slurped some water
all right ah no wait um spear
right i'm just gonna make a lot of
non-upgraded spears and that way
i can lose them and huck them exactly
how do you make a spear again
i've forgotten am i dumb yes
oh you can only have one well that's
stupid this is
dumb so i think we did cave
nine yeah i think i know how to get to
cave
one yes oh oh oh chase and lizard
all right fine you remember about
birthdays and yeah that's bad
it really got this lizard for me though
it really did that so uh honestly
that was a good birthday all right get
some dried meat for the road
and i'm good to go
just just practicing your spears
yeah yeah well i don't want to lose you
this time and i really want to know
exactly where i'm hitting
whoa wait what the f it where'd they go
yours is there yours is there but
where'd mine go go wait where's mine i
don't see mine
it's in the it's in the rack you don't
see it right in front of me no
oh i don't see it well i disappeared i
collected it
i saw you just grab it do do spears have
like durability on being thrown because
that just disappeared no
not that i know i've thrown mine and got
mine back several times damn it
looks like i'm making another spear boy
this squirrel doesn't give a
[ __ ] and it's dead how do i make a spear
what was it mark it's i don't know man i
only made the one and i couldn't
remember the recipe
oh it's just two sticks got it and
somewhere
over here uh there's a cave
okay cool maybe to the right okay i'm
gonna look right
look for cracks okay look for cracks
looks for cracks you might want to climb
up in
okay is it possible up on the cliff we
have to go down don't go this way
there's a people
uh rabbit missed by that much
two rabbits where'd it go
where'd it go rabbit damn it
i really wish there was an interactive
map finding caves
is a real pain in the b-hole well if we
get the cave with the map in it then we
will be able to
start charting everything i see oh i'm
in a village
i don't think that's quite right there's
a picture of it
a man handing a child a gun i got that
one it's a good one
i may have misunderstood the map
actually a little bit
damn it god damn it
this [ __ ] rabbit bob you want me to
pull up the map for a second opinion i
think i have a thought
go back to the water okay and i may have
misunderstood the angles
i may have vectored this inaccurately
okay i've come from the water
so we're at the water so
we kind of want to go we're throwing
your spirit there's rabbits oh [ __ ]
where did
i try to understand the throwing arc
it's very confusing at times
it should be maybe this away this away
okay okay okay sure
isn't this one of the caves that we just
went
oh no it didn't it's up here for some
reason bob i'm starting to think that
i don't think i know how to read maps i
think you might be reading this map
wrong
i'll go i can go i'll go look let me let
me look like a second opinion that's all
i don't doubt you but just like
second opinion you know oh you're
looking for cave one right
yes okay okay let me let me i think we
are close
you find it mark uh looking still
looking
oh no oh there's many arms and many legs
wade don't come over here
all right don't don't you talked me into
it i will not oh look
that's what's roaring hey you guys
having good luck over there
there's a spider oh there's fast ones
hey bud
oh this guy's oh oh oh my god what
happened
what i clicked out oh god oh god oh god
oh my god you're right uh not for long i
accidentally clicked out of the game bob
there's a bunch of normal
small guys running with them that are
coming your way yeah they're so fast
they're like spider monkeys i feel like
the cave is supposed to be right here
uh ah i don't want to doubt you but i
don't think so i think it's near
did you find it uh well i was about to i
think anyway but i got
i got attacked a couple times philly is
right here somewhere
are we crazy i think you're obviously
cause i'm pretty sure it's right here
one oh there's two ones there's two one
there's multiple one cave entrances oh
wait which one
is there no entrance and an exit i mean
both right it doesn't help that this
this map was drawn in ms paint
it doesn't quite help they didn't
move anything did they is this like an
outdated map
well this map isn't helpful at all i'm
an idiot you're an idiot
i'm an idiot why because i'm an idiot
okay
okay okay okay okay okay okay okay okay
that's the waterfall that's the
waterfall okay
i know where it is you know where it is
i know where
it is sure about that i do
the one in ms paint is stupid it's very
dumb
it makes no sense and it's dumb but this
one
actually has it looks like it's a
topographical map
not 100 sure what topographical means
but it means that i know where the cave
is
oh found it god here mark you find it
yeah i did
it is not what i thought we would have
been looking for oh
damn i walked you right by this yeah
no that other came that other came that
come
give me your calm see you later boys see
you later boys
boys see you later boys thank god
there's no such thing as rope see you in
a little bit boys
this is a pretty deep cave boys we're
going
deep boys oh wow
ooh cloth i love cloth plenty of cloth
drawings wow look at this one
drawings wow dude i love your paint hold
anymore
kind of some kind of a door with so i
found a toy part guys i found broken toy
parts
oh yeah yeah yeah this kid went down in
a plane crash would he really draw a
picture of him happily
under a plane i don't know what kids do
man
i haven't met a kid in years they're
messed up they would do whatever they
want yeah kids are weird
anybody got mad i am the establishment i
am almost dead
meds yeah oh hey bud oh dear
oh he has arms look at the arms he has
there are no arms on this dude no no the
one orphan
come look at the man who orfs what are
you talking about many many arms
you know what it might be prudent to
have chainsaws up my dudes
maybe maybe all right i'm gonna go ahead
and just
chainsaw myself into one of my spots
here
yeah oh they run what do they where oh
they move oh oh oh
oh not a fan all right actually this is
perfect this is perfect this part
oh jesus
the range you know that uh famous guy
meds i'm feeling pretty
okay that's okay one at a time is not a
big deal
i'm spearing only because i cannot
handle that
okay i did anyone got tnt dynamite we
had some of that back at the base but
i got something better wait wait we have
a molotov yeah yeah i'll make a
why didn't it dude did you just
wait there's a ramp that comes up here
did you not light it at the moment oh my
god i got it yeah i got
it i got it i got it don't worry i'll
hold them off
three two one watch out bob
oh yes oh you didn't get the one that we
really want
yeah he really hurts all right i'll make
another one hang on
i got it i got it well just in case we
need a third oh
yeah that was a good shot that was a
good shot behind us
no wait no we're fine mark you can't
just say something like it sounded like
there was someone behind us
watch out bob i'm gonna throw another
yeah
got him
everyone's laughing because i didn't
like the first molotov i didn't know
very funny okay i got i got my next one
ready but you guys go ahead
oh okay i've got another
they're all burning now
i leave the mullets off and then put it
in my pocket is that dangerous
oh no it's probably fun all right are
you
someone got the next one i'll get this
one man we are lucky that there's this
ledger because they
they don't want to die from downtown
oh yeah
oh you lit them on fire perfectly in
time for that to be
my nightmare holy [ __ ]
all right you got the next small top one
i want to throw i want to get in one i
got the next next
are you good you get the next one yeah
you got a nice you got this
all right okay
maybe it doesn't i don't know maybe just
hurting them at all nicely roasted you'd
think that this spear would have more
range but it really don't
all right i'm gonna do another molly
okay go for it
hopefully that that was yay well you're
right
god can this thing die it looks like
they really want me right here can some
of you like go to the right if if it's
like sweet yeah i'm gonna do another
molly and then i'm gonna
oh he did oh
oh we should probably save our stuff
then oh [ __ ] they're all dead
i'm going to chop it up just in case
let's go let's make a fire
frickin oh yeah burn the bodies see what
kind of goods you get
get the booze oh my god i'm getting its
creepy armor
i'm gonna get burnt did i put it on my
leg do i have leg goop
armor i don't know man man i really
don't want it but also we probably need
that
yeah well it's not my leg it's not it's
not it's not a terrible thing to have
um i found oh it's on my hand
oh hey uh hi okay thank you for the
cloth
i like your whitey tighties ah you're
right there look
i hate it i actually hate it i hate the
way it looks i hate how slimy it looks
yeah it's it's not the best surprisingly
few bones on these
people is this body is the big body not
quite in the fire
so how much molotovs do we have i have
uh i can make like three more yeah i can
make
four more bottles i'm gonna just
pre-make them because i'm
pretty sure i don't need anything else
besides this
hey mark yeah right behind you buddy
great i'm not right behind you buddy
don't hustle or anything
i would never water
i saw you guys for like a glimpse really
a glimpse of a second
one for a second well hurry just uh just
a flash of a moment
oh hey hi look at this guy
oh you got the goop arm i got a goopy
leg hanging out
there's two pounds travel
i'll go down the other one see if the
other what new animal discovered what
guys the the guy who's dead is wearing
an iheart travel shirt
what are the odds bats here oh hey look
at those guys
yeah oh
did we all three just like no i don't
know
i thought we were all just like look up
look how cool they are
oh look a beautiful little yellow
creature
i wonder if i can kill it no
everyone heard that right why wasn't
anyone else afraid i'm afraid
well i mean i'm hoping that it'll go for
the person
screaming out loud and not me they can't
hear us you goofball you
don't know that hey meds oh sweet meds
there's still that path back there i
wonder what's down the other way we'll
probably come back to it
i'm sure i think the ones like the way
down one's the way up or something no i
mean
it probably just branches into multiple
places okay well this is a
i found something over here there's like
a cross collectible
it's just the dead end mark if you want
to come back and get the cross i'm gonna
see where this is going
a little bit oh boy yeah wait where did
mark go he went there's a path to the
right there but there's like a
collectible right here before we okay
i'm coming back
i'm getting cold my dudes i'm getting
hurt guys you want to play skull slammys
yeah skull skull slammies
this is from that drawing can we get
through this
oh wait yeah can we like oh we totally
can like break this down oh the chainsaw
yeah
oh yeah well i bet you could just use
your axe normal
turns out a stick was not good enough
but that's pretty efficient
well it's not like we have a limited
amount of axe fuel or anything i mean
chainsaw fuel
well whatever it's fine
secret oh god
[Music]
hey how's it going ah
could you do me a favor and open this
door
i would really appreciate that i need to
[Music]
get in and i can't because
this door is closed so if you could just
open it up for me that would be really
good